WAI CHEE DIMOCK: I'd like
to refresh your
memories by going
back to talk
briefly about the two classes
last week on Faulkner.
And we looked at Faulkner's
remark at the Nagano Seminar
in Japan, when he claimed that
The Sound and the Fury is the
same story told four times.
So in light of that claim, we
looked at the relation between
Benjy and Quentin as a relation
of kinship and variation.
The two of them are obviously
brothers, but they can also be
seen as brothers in more than
just a biological sense.
So let's think about kinship
and variation as the most
fundamental structure of
The Sound and the Fury.
And so far, what we can see is
that this structure of kinship
and variation is pivoted on some
kind of battle with time.
As we know, Benjy wants Caddy
never to grow up.
He wants her always to be an
innocent young girl, never to
become a woman.
He wants her always to "smell
like trees." That's the
signature line from Benjy.
In many ways, it is
a battle for an
impossible, unchanging
innocence.
And we know that the nature of
the battle is such that Benjy
is destined to be a loser.
There's no way he can
win that battle.
But we also know that the very
fact that this is an
impossible battle, that Benjy
is destined to be a loser,
also means that it's going
to be a narrative
challenge for Faulkner.
He has to do something
for the loser.
If you are a good author,
you want to do
something for the loser.
And so one of the challenges for
Faulkner in The Sound and
the Fury is to do something
for Benjy.
If we turn to Quentin, we see
pretty much the same pattern
repeated, the same
battle with time.
Quentin is exactly like Benjy
in that he also wants Caddy
never to grow up.
He wants her always to be an
innocent young girl, never to
become a grown woman with
her own sexuality.
And so in that way, it's an
almost complete replay of that
impossible demand from Benjy.
But Quentin has an additional
battle with time, a more
abstract battle.
And we see that in the opening
of the Quentin section, he
takes out his watch, he smashes
the crystal, and then
he twists off the hands
of the watch.
And he injures his hand
in the process.
So right then, we know
that it's a losing
battle for him too.
But he twists off the hands
of the watch, and
the watch ticks on.
That's a little local allegory
for the entire course of
Quentin's section.
So at the end of Quentin's
section, we know that the most
offending word, and that he
calls the saddest word of all,
is the word "temporary." And
by "temporary," he has one
particular context in mind.
His tragedy, as we have
seen, is basically
a secondhand tragedy.
It is not his own tragedy.
It is the secondhand tragedy of
Caddy losing her virginity.
But Quentin is embracing it
as his own tragedy and is
basically finishing, wrapping
up his life as a response to
that tragedy.
But the fear is that that
tragedy is going to pass, that
it's not going to be a permanent
tragedy for him.
Everything is temporary.
Even the sense of devastation
will go away.
So because "temporary" is the
saddest word of all, the only
way Quentin can get around
that word is to have a
preemptive strike against
that word.
His suicide is a preemptive
strike against the word
"temporary," so that it will
have an artificial permanence
in his own life, because his
life is ended at that moment,
and there's no possibility for
it to fade away, to become
less devastating.
So in those ways, Benjy and
Quentin are very much brothers
in a spiritual sense, a
metaphoric battle with time.
Today, we'll move on to Jason.
And it's a bigger challenge to
think of Jason as the brother
to Quentin and Benjy.
Jason seems very, very different
on the face of it.
But I'd like to suggest that in
at least one way, Jason can
be seen as a brother to Benjy
and Quentin, in that he also
has his own battle with time.
And it is a battle
with a larger
constellation of forces.
So we are seeing scale
enlargement in a very
significant way in the
Jason section.
We're seeing a much bigger
picture of the United States.
And that scale enlargement has
to do with a tug of war
between the yesterday of the
United States and the tomorrow
of the United States and Jason
wanting very much to cling to
the yesterday.
It's more congenial to
him in every way.
But at the same time,
he knows that the
tomorrow is already here.
In fact, the tomorrow is
encroaching on the present.
There's nothing he
can do about it.
He just has to learn to cope
with that tomorrow, very
uncongenial, very threatening
tomorrow.
He has to learn to come
to terms with that.
So the basic dynamic of Jason's
section is the battle
between yesterday
and tomorrow.
And I think that we know that
it pretty much is a losing
battle for Jason as well.
Because we're talking so much
about yesterday and tomorrow,
I want to bring back that very
important passage from
Macbeth, Act V, Scene 5, that
Faulkner took the phrase "the
sound and the fury" from.
"Tomorrow, and tomorrow, and
tomorrow, creeps in this petty
pace from day to
day to the last
syllable of recorded time.
And all our yesterdays have
lighted fools the
way to dusty death.
It is a tale told by an idiot,
full of sound and fury,
signifying nothing."
So Faulkner is really
getting the maximum
mileage from that passage.
He's really taking out the
entire scaffolding of his
novel from that Shakespeare
passage.
And I'd like to give you a brief
overview of the basic
structure of today's lecture,
the various terms that come
into play in this tug
of war between
yesterday and tomorrow.
We know that the horse is
actually still a presence in
The Sound and the Fury.
Queenie, the horse, will have
a starring role at the very
end of the novel.
We don't see her quite in the
foreground yet, but I promise
you she'll have a
starring role.
We know that the automobile
is very much here.
And I would like to think of
those, the horse and the
automobile, as two directional
arrows.
So the horse is a vector, is a
directional arrow pointing
back to the 19th century, a very
genteel world where to
own a horse makes you a part
of the gentry as well as
civility of social
distinctions.
The automobile, as we already
have seen in The Great Gatsby,
is a vehicle that to some
extent breaks down or
complicates social
distinctions.
It also brings in strangers.
So the phrase that I would like
to use to think about
that transition from the past to
the present is the concept
that I'm taking from the
literary and cultural critic
Raymond Williams, the notion of
the knowable community and
how that's receding into the
past, that's breaking down to
be replaced by an unknowable
world of strangers.
And on that basis, I'll talk
about the basic structure,
really, in the Jason section as
two patterns of grievances,
two patterns of injury.
As we know, Jason is someone who
feels grief all the time.
He feels that the whole
world has done him an
unpardonable wrong.
So he's complaining
all the time.
That's his mode.
But given that this is the
baseline for Jason, he has two
different parties, two different
kinds of people,
that he's complaining about.
One is the known parties,
people in his immediate
environment, people he
knows very well.
And then there are total
strangers who are also doing
him a wrong, that he knows
nothing about, but he's
convinced are out to get him.
So the notion that there are
strangers somewhere to get you
versus people right here
who are doing you in
right on the spot.
And so the people who are right
there are his family,
his servants, his father,
his niece, Quentin.
And the unknown parties include
the usual suspects,
New York Jew, US government,
Western Union Telegraph, and
of course Wall Street.
So very familiar.
Again, very close
to us, actually.
But this is the image that
I find in some sense is a
capsule summary of the dynamics
in the Jason section.
You see the horse and cart, the
nineteenth-century relic,
and then the automobile
coming right--
almost going to run
it over, we fear.
And that's the situation that
we get in The Sound and the
Fury in the Jason section.
We know that Jason actually is
part of the future, he's part
of tomorrow, in the sense
that he owns a car.
And he's very proud.
He's seen in his car a lot, and
he's very proud that his
is a relatively expensive car.
It's not a Ford.
He makes a point that there are
people who own Fords, but
his car is not a Ford.
We don't know what kind of a
car he has, but it's a car
that he's proud of and he
spends a lot of time in.
But there's a basic
incompatibility between Jason
and his car.
And this comes back to
the Compson curse.
It turns out that Jason's
faculty of smell is as highly
developed as his
two brothers'.
In his case, the smell that gets
to him isn't the smell of
trees or the smell of
honeysuckle but
the smell of gasoline.
He can't stand the smell
of gasoline.
It gives him a tremendous
headache.
The only way he can drive is
by putting a handkerchief
soaked in camphor
over his nose.
That's the only way he can
drive his own car.
So this is his complaint about
this vehicle that belongs to
him, that he wouldn't dream of
getting rid of, but is a
burden to him.
"And now I reckon I'll get home
just in time to take a
nice long drive after a basket
of tomatoes or something and
then have to go back to town
smelling like a camphor
factory so my head won't explode
right on my shoulders.
I says, you don't know
what a headache is.
I says, you think I'd fool with
that damn car at all if
it depended on me?"
Of course, he's complaining that
it's not by choice that
he's in this car, but we
also know that he's
proud of his car.
So this is just to
lay out a basic
difficulty in Jason's situation.
It's that there's a tension,
a conflict between his own
physical well being and the most
basic ingredient of an
automobile, of structural
incompatibility between Jason
as a biological human being
and the mechanical
workings of a car.
But beyond that, there's also
something else that makes the
automobile a terrible threat to
Jason, which is the kinds
of people who come
with automobiles.
And already, we're beginning
to see a world of strangers
opening up right there in
Jefferson, Mississippi.
So here's Jason.
"I had just turned onto the
street when I saw a Ford
coming helling toward me.
All of a sudden, it stopped.
I could hear the wheels sliding,
and it slewed around
and backed and whirled.
And just as I was thinking what
the hell they were up to,
I saw that red tie.
Then I recognized
her face looking
back through the window.
I saw red.
When I recognized that red tie,
after all I had told her,
I forgot about everything.
I never thought about my head,
even, until I came to the
first forks and had to stop.
Yet we spend money and spend
money on roads, and damn if it
isn't like trying to drive over
a sheet of corrugated
iron roofing.
I would like to know how a man
could be expected to keep up
with even a wheelbarrow."
In the space of two paragraphs,
we see that Jason
has shifted his attention from
his niece, Quentin, to the
government who's not keeping
up the roads.
So the first thing that we can
say about this passage is that
the word "temporary" isn't
just a curse for Quentin.
It is also a curse for Jason.
He has a very short
attention span.
He can't really keep his mind
fixed on the thing that he's
going to complain against.
And that's just a
little aside.
It's not something that
Jason himself notices.
But we can say that for him.
That's one strike against him in
his battle with time, that
he has such a short attention
span and that he can't hold
onto what little time that he
has, or that he can't make
that time last longer,
can't make his
grievance last longer.
So not being able to make
something last longer is one
of the problems with Jason.
And that's a long-term, generic,
constitutional
problem for Jason.
But the most immediate problem
for him is that his niece,
Quentin, the daughter of Caddy,
is running around with
total strangers.
And we don't know
who this man is.
Jason is not telling us, because
he doesn't know.
All he can see is that this is a
man with a red tie, and that
tells him that this man is
no good and that Quentin
shouldn't be hanging out with
this man wearing a red tie.
And he comes with a car
that's a relatively--
I don't myself consider a Ford
a cheap car, but Jason
considers it a cheap car, and
therefore that's another
strike against the stranger
that he's no good.
In the next-- so this
is on Page 238--
next page, we know who
this stranger is.
Not really what kind of a person
he is, but what kind of
occupation he has.
"I says, as far as I'm
concerned, let her go to hell
as fast as she pleases, and
the sooner the better.
I says, what else do you expect
except every damn
drummer and cheap show that
comes to town, because even
those town jellybeans give
her the go-by now."
And that shows how far the
Compson fortune has fallen
from being the town gentry.
Quentin has fallen so low
that even the town
jellybeans won't touch her.
The only way she can have some
company is to hang out with
strangers coming to town
for the first time.
Cheap shows --
it's confusing to see the
drummer in the context of a
cheap show.
We might think that the drummer
is someone who plays
the drums. But actually, no,
this is a specialized, late
nineteenth-century, turn
of the century, early
twentieth-century slang word
for the traveling salesman.
So Jason is using that very
distinct period usage.
The drummer --
this is a traveling salesman.
We know that he's going to be
there probably just for a day
to keep Quentin company,
and then he'll be gone.
So Jason in that way is an entry
point for us to that
nineteenth-century world,
the changing world of
salesmanship, of marketing.
That's very important, that we
have traveling salesmen who
drive around in cars,
fast-living traveling salesmen.
All of those are new
developments.
And the other thing we can say
about this drummer is that
he's known to Jason, to the
extent that he is known at
all, primarily because
of two attributes.
One is the thing that stands out
from him, is the fact that
he's wearing a red tie.
That's a giveaway for Jason.
And the other thing is that
his occupation is
written on his face.
The fact that he's a traveling
salesman is clear just from--
anyone can see that
that's what he is.
So Jason's knowledge of the
drummer doesn't extend
further than that.
It is a very superficial
knowledge of this man.
Not because Jason doesn't want
to know him-- well, maybe
Jason doesn't--
in any case, that knowledge will
never extend further than
the color of his tie and
occupational label that Jason
can pin on him.
It is a world that is by
definition made up of our
superficial knowledge of total
strangers, people we see once
and never again.
That is the world that is
opening up in front of Jason.
We can decide whether or
not this is a world
that we like or not.
We have no choice.
I think that this is also the
world that we are in.
Quite often, most of the people
that we meet actually
are people we see once and never
again, that we know just
by those two attributes, what
kind of clothes they wear and
our surmises as to what kind of
occupations they have. So
Jason's tomorrow is in many
ways our present.
And here, I want to mention the
work of one of my heroes,
really, Raymond Williams, a very
influential literary and
cultural critic.
He died some time ago.
His classic work, The Country
and the City, in that work,
Raymond Williams coins the
phrase "knowable communities."
In fact, one of the chapters
of the book is called
"Knowable Communities."
And this is what Raymond
Williams says.
"A country community, most
typically a village, is an
epitome of direct relationships,
of face-to-face
contacts within which we can
find and value the substance
of personal relationships.
As the scale and complexity of
the characteristic social
organizations increase, a
whole community, wholly
knowable, becomes harder
and harder to sustain."
So Raymond Williams' idea is
that modernity is defined by
the breakdown of that
unsustainable utopian ideal,
knowable communities.
And he really reads
almost all--
he was English, so he reads
almost all of English
literature using that concept,
and I'm extending his insight
to American literature.
And here I want to stop very
briefly and say a word about
plagiarism.
I know that the first paper
is coming up for you guys.
And I just want to emphasize
how important it is to
acknowledge where you're getting
your ideas, where
you're getting your
wording from.
"Knowable community" is a phrase
that I could have made
up myself, but it is really
important to acknowledge the
book or the article that you
got the concept from.
Very, very important
for two reasons.
One is that it is just a
courtesy, needed recognition
to the person who came
up with the idea.
If you were to come up with
a great phrase, you'd want
people to acknowledge you.
But I think that more than that,
I think that citational
practices are not just a
technicality, are not just a
way to get ourselves
out of trouble.
It is a way to show that we're
in dialogue with someone else.
And because Raymond Williams
is such a hero for me, I
actually take a lot of pleasure
in thinking that even
though he didn't write about
Faulkner, that actually his
insights apply so well
to Faulkner.
So it is the pleasure of having
a long and extended
conversation with people that
you admire, whose work you
enjoy reading.
So for both those two reasons,
please acknowledge where
you're getting your
ideas from.
So using Raymond Williams'
idea of the knowable
community, I want to think about
Jason's structure of
injury, his pattern of injury.
And I'll be looking at two
passages that suggest that
he's still in a knowable
community, and then we'll move
on to that much more pressing,
the world is going to win out,
the world that is made up
of unknowable strangers.
But first, knowable community
based on Jefferson,
Mississippi.
This is Jason at breakfast.
"Once a bitch, always
a bitch, what I say.
I says, you're lucky if her
playing out of school is all
that worries you.
I says, she ought to be down
there in that kitchen right
now instead of up there in her
room, gobbing paint on her
face, and waiting for six
niggers that can't even stand
up out of a chair unless they've
got a pan full of
bread and meat to balance them,
to fix breakfast for
her."
So one of the basic problems
for Jason that we noticed
earlier, the very short
attention span, is very much
in evidence here.
He starts off complaining
against his niece, Quentin.
By the end of that passage,
he's complaining about the
"niggers" in his household.
So he can't hold onto a
grievance for very long.
The word "temporary" is
definitely a curse for him.
But even though the word
"temporary" is a curse for
Jason, he actually aspires
to permanence.
And we see that in the opening
line of that passage, "Once a
bitch, always a a bitch."
It is not a proverb.
There's no such proverb
in the world.
But it has the feel
of a proverb.
It has the feel of a
proverb-like permanence.
And this is the small-town Jason
who is speaking, finding
enormous satisfaction from
making pronouncements that
sound like proverbs.
This is his take on the world,
and he's able to sum up the
entire world just using
seven words.
You can't really do better
than that, a seven-word
summation of the entire world.
So just enormous satisfaction.
So we can say that even though
Jason is complaining nonstop,
even though that's his mode,
this is one instance where
complaining is actually
a very pleasurable
activity for Jason.
He's getting a kick being able
to say that his niece is a
bitch, and she'll
always be one.
And he's getting a kick out of
talking about the thickness of
her makeup, and everything that
is objectionable about
her gives him enormous
pleasure.
So complaining in a world
of known quantities--
and Quentin is very much a
known quantity to Jason--
complaining about people right
around you, people in your
immediate family, that's a
really fun thing to do.
And Jason is having
fun doing that.
He's having fun complaining
about the black servants.
And in his mind, as far as he's
concerned, Quentin, his
niece, and those black servants
are exactly alike.
They are all good for nothing.
They are all a trial for him.
They're all wronging him
in some fashion.
They're a drain on his financial
resources, a drain
on his patience.
It's just a burden that he has
to carry through life, that he
happens to have a niece
like that and to have
servants like that.
And he can go on and on.
He can go on all
day like this.
And it would be a very happy
life for him to be able to go
on like that.
So this is the pleasure
that one gets
from a knowable community.
And I'll just give you another
instance of that, very much in
the same vein.
"Like I say, if he had to sell
something to send Quentin to
Harvard, we'd all be a damn
sight better off if he'd sold
that sideboard and bought
himself a one-armed
straitjacket with part
of the money.
I reckon the reason all the
Compson gave out before it got
to me, like Mother says,
is that he drank it up.
At least I never heard of him
offering to sell anything to
send me to Harvard."
So two complaints here,
both centered on
his father, Mr. Compson.
One is that his father drinks.
And in fact it is true that
one of the many metaphoric
punctuation marks in The Sound
and the Fury, Mr. Compson
making the trips to the
sideboard to get the booze,
that's one of the punctuation
marks in The
Sound and the Fury.
So Jason isn't wrong that his
father drinks and probably is
squandering away the whole
Compson fortune, to the extent
that there is one now.
He's squandering away the whole
fortune by drinking, so
Jason has a legitimate
complaint.
But a deeper complaint that goes
along with the fact that
his father drinks is that
Quentin, his brother, was his
father's favorite, that his
father, as much as he loves
drinking, he probably
loved Quentin better
than he loved alcohol.
And he would go so far as to
sell the pastures, Benjy's
pastures, so that Quentin
would go to Harvard.
Of course, he killed himself
after one year, so all of the
money was wasted, and that is
just even more grounds for
complaint for Jason.
Once again, I have to say, it's
a very understandable
grievance, the sense of not
being loved, the sense that
nobody has ever done anything
for him, that everything that
could be done in that family
was being done for Quentin,
who wasted everything.
I wouldn't say it's a completely
legitimate
grievance, but it's a very
understandable grievance of
why he's someone that
nobody thinks about.
Nobody ever gives a thought to
the well-being of Jason.
And what kind of a monster do
you get when nobody ever gives
a thought to his well-being?
So in many ways, Faulkner--
and I'm just preparing you for
the ending of The Sound and
the Fury, where I do think that
even though Jason is a
loser, once again, Faulkner does
something for that loser.
He's a very sad loser.
And here we see some of the
reason for that sadness.
It's that people turn into
monsters when they feel that
they're completely unloved.
But still, right now, along with
the self-pity, along with
the constant complaining,
Jason is getting some
satisfaction from the fact that
he's complaining against
his father, once again, a known
quantity to him, known
all too well in this instance.
So let's look at the breakdown
of that knowable world,
because it's satisfying
to Jason.
That's the thing that's going
to be taken away from him.
The last thing that gives him
satisfaction is going to be
taken away from him.
And the breakdown of the
knowable community comes with
the automobile, as we have seen,
and all those things
that are intimated by the
arrival of the automobile--
the New York Jew, the US
government, Western Union, and
Wall Street.
So let's look at one instance
of Jason's sense that he's
wronged by unknown parties.
And all of a sudden, we see that
the world has expanded
tremendously, that even though
Jason is still in Jefferson,
Mississippi, that all of a
sudden, New York City becomes
his horizon, becomes his
reference point.
"I don't see how a city no
bigger than New York can hold
enough people to take
the money away
from us country suckers.
Well, I'm done with them.
They've sucked me in
for the last time.
Any fool except a fellow that
hasn't got any more sense than
to take a Jew's word for
anything could tell the market
was going up all the time,
with the whole damn delta
about to be flooded again and
the cotton washed right out of
the ground like it
was last year.
Let it wash a man's crop out of
the ground year after year,
and then up there in Washington,
spending $50,000 a
year keeping an army in
Nicaragua or some place."
Incredible scale enlargement
in the world of Jason, not
only New York City, but Central
America as well.
So we have to figure out why
it is that the world is
suddenly opening up in
this drastic fashion.
And it turns out that actually
closer to home, there's
actually a significant Jewish
population, Jewish community,
in Clarksdale, Mississippi.
So Jason could have seen these
people, he could have
socialized with his Jewish
neighbors, but he's not
thinking about his
Jewish neighbors.
Because he's talking about New
York City, he also could have
been talking about Lower East
Side and Hester Street.
And this is a picture of Hester
Street, turn of the century.
These are not very threatening
people.
Jason could have been talking
about those Jews,
those New York Jews.
He's not thinking about those.
Instead, the New York Jew that
he has in mind is very
similar, is a kind of
transnational Jew.
This is a picture by the
French painter Degas.
I think that we know him
probably from all his
paintings of the
ballet dancers.
So we think of him as a painter
of very graceful
bodies in motion.
But he actually also has a whole
range of paintings about
social portraits.
And this is a painting of a
French Jewish banker at the
French Bourse--
stock exchange --
in Paris and the machinations
engaged in by the proverbial,
I guess, transnational Jew,
always scheming and conspiring
for no good.
Jason's image of the New York
Jew has everything in common
with this anti-Semitic image
in Degas' painting.
And so we can see that really
the whole financial world is
really opening up in
the Jason section.
But there's one other
detail that we get.
And in this way, Jason's also a
guide for us to the world of
the 1920s, basically the whole
of the early twentieth
century, because of his
mention to Nicaragua.
And it turns out that that's
actually an accurate mention.
The United States was in
Nicaragua from 1909 to 1933.
In 1916, getting closer
to the date of The
Sound and the Fury--
The Sound and the Fury,
let me just say, was
published in 1929.
So keep that date in
your mind, 1929.
But in any case, in 1916,
there was the
Chamorro-Bryan Treaty.
It was ratified by the US Senate
in 1916, and it gave
the United States exclusive
rights to build an
inter-oceanic canal
across Nicaragua.
The Panama Canal was already
in existence, but there was
some thought that maybe another
canal might be useful.
And the United States was
claiming exclusive rights to
build that canal.
And that treaty also turned
Nicaragua into a near US
protectorate, so that's Jason's
complaint about the
$50,000 every day spent to keep
an army in Nicaragua.
So Jason is someone who reads
the newspapers, clearly.
He's a good newspaper reader.
He's up on the news.
He has almost legitimate
complaints against the US
government and the foreign
intervention of the US
government and the drain
on the finances
of the United States.
And so all of a sudden, there's
a conflation of the
New York Jew, the US government,
strangers at a
distance, up to no good.
So people who are far away, you
never set sight on them,
they are harming you
in some fashion.
Let's look at another
way in which--
and here, in the earlier
passage, when the US
government is just spending
$50,000 a day in Nicaragua,
Jason himself claims to be
completely innocent.
He's just harmed by the foreign
policy of the United
States government.
But in the next passage, we see
that actually Jason is in
some sense a willing party to
the harm that is coming to him
in the sense that he is
complicitous in the world that
he's complaining about.
And this is also the second
instance of injury from
unknown parties.
"Damn if I believe anybody knows
anything about the damn
thing except the ones that sit
back in those New York offices
and watch the country suckers
come up and beg them to take
their money.
Only be damned if it doesn't
look like a company as big and
rich as Western Union could
get a market report out on
time half as quick as they'll
get a wire to you saying your
account closed out.
But what the hell do care
about the people?
They're hand in glove with
the New York crowd.
Anybody could see that."
Why is Jason so obsessed with
Western Union and with the
telegraph as a newly developed
instrumentality of
communication?
Well, it turns out that he's a
small investor, and he wants
to find out exactly how
his stocks are doing.
He wants to be able to invest
or withdraw his money.
So the Western Union
is crucial.
His relation to Wall Street is
crucial, but the Western Union
is crucial in getting those
reports to him on time and
allowing him to change his
investments on time.
And it turns out that the
Western Union was in fact a
very common sight
in the South.
There were many telegraph
offices in the South.
And this is the main Western
Union office in New York City.
So once again, Jason really
knows what he's talking about.
He's naming entities
that actually were
real historical entities.
And here's a bank.
This is a historic bank on the
historic Oxford Square in
Oxford, Mississippi--
that is Jefferson,
Mississippi--
and this is the main square in
town, so banks were also a
very important presence in
Oxford, Mississippi.
And it's really Jason's
relationship to the banks,
both the local banks and also
the national banks on Wall
Street by way of the mediator,
by the Western Union, that
really is the main relation
in his life.
Yes, he has a relation to
his niece, Quentin.
He has a relation
to his mother.
He has a relation to
his black servants.
He hates them all.
And the most significant
relation that he has is to his
money, held in jeopardy
now by the national
banks on Wall Street.
And it is in that context
that all of a sudden the
proverb-like phrase reappears,
but in a very sad, almost a
plea from Jason.
"Like I say, once a bitch,
always a bitch.
And just let me have 24 hours
without any damn New York Jew
to advise me what it's
going to do.
I don't want to make
a killing.
Save that to suck in the
smart gamblers with.
I just want an even chance
to get my money back."
I think that that is
the very small hope
on the part of Jason.
He's not asking to make
a huge sum of money.
He just doesn't want to
lose all his money.
And it's such a modest
hope that we know
it's bound to be defeated.
Because of course, in such a
world of long-distance action
and a world operated by total
strangers with huge,
large-scale, impersonal
institutions, small investors
are the ones who lose out.
So it's a phenomenon that
we recognize very well.
In that way, I think that we
shouldn't forget that just as
Faulkner has a lot of sympathy
for Benjy, Faulkner also has a
lot of sympathy for Jason.
It's very hard for us as readers
to have any sympathy
for Jason at all.
He's just such an offensive,
off-putting character.
But I think that that very
resonant, small plea-- "I just
want an even chance to
get my money back"--
in that one phrase,
Jason in many ways
speaks for all of us.
And Faulkner knows it, that that
is in many ways the most
important phrase in
the Jason section.
And as it turns out, the irony
of history is such that the
history of the United States
turns out to be a corridor to
The Sound and the Fury.
Because the same year that The
Sound and the Fury came out
was also the year
of the crash.
And here is an image of the
trading floor of the New York
Stock Exchange and two more
images, the crowds outside the
New York Stock Exchange.
All those people are probably
much bigger
investors than Jason.
They're right there
on the spot.
They're probably
big investors.
They're the traders, actually.
A lot of them were traders.
So they were insiders
on Wall Street.
But even the insiders had the
illusory sense that if you
could just be there physically,
that that would
make a difference.
So this proves that Raymond
Williams' idea of the knowable
community is actually
a psychological
demand from all of us.
All of us want to know the
people we're having
transactions with.
All of us are creating knowable
communities right
around us, even though the
actual, historical
circumstances are making those
knowable communities an
impossible ideal
in the present.
So we know that those people are
there on the spot trying
to recreate in vain a utopian
ideal from the past. And even
though they're not country
suckers like Jason, in the
sense that they are not from
Mississippi, they resemble him
in more ways than one.
So in that sense, the Jason
section represents the largest
possible scale for Faulkner.
It really is about the entire
world captured by Jason's
dealings and his failed attempt
to come to terms with
the future.
The tomorrow that he's guiding
us to is really no place to
be, but I think that for him and
for lots of other people,
that is the present.
But for Jason, it's the problem
of trying to find a
resting place, a sustainable or
some kind of bearable place
in that tomorrow.
That's going to be the challenge
for Faulkner in the
last section of The Sound
and the Fury.
So we'll come back to an
alternative to the automobile
at the very end of The Sound
and the Fury and Jason's
satisfaction with that.